this great big story was made possible
by
fairmont in a core hotel experience
[Music]
a lot of people ask what does the
shanghai restoration project mean
and it's inspired by the 1930s shanghai
jazz scene
back then you had musicians from all
different cultural backgrounds that came
together to make a music that couldn't
be attributed to any particular culture
or nationality
what we wanted to do was sort of revive
this spirit
my name is dave liang my name is
we're the shanghai restoration project
[Music]
the shanghai restoration project has
been around since 2005. we started
performing as a duo i think the first
time in 2016.
we've released maybe 14-15 albums these
are some of the artworks that i've done
for our album covers
we've played at the rio cinema in london
the concrete and grass festival in
shanghai played the great wall of china
[Applause]
[Music]
i grew up in china and they grew up here
but to a chinese immigrant family when
we first met i would ask him like why do
you use so many chinese instruments
i never listened to chinese folk
musician growing up
growing up i listened to all sorts of
genres but the one thing that just stuck
out were these chinese instruments you
know in my home they were just like
nothing else that i heard
[Music]
i think our merger of culture merger of
perspectives also influenced our music
what you'll hear in our music are
harmonic rhythmical and melodic
influences from all over the world
you'll hear sounds from china you'll
hear sounds from brazil influences from
senegal or ethiopia or france or
portugal
the process of creating a new sound is
always different
we use a lot of samples from everyday
objects
we tend to go to a lot of random places
for touring or for travel and every
place has a very unique sound
sometimes when we're intrigued by a
sound in the street we'll just like take
out our phone or a recorder to record
the sound
we were in london at the tape museum
even fan had bought a poster and she
just started hitting it against her leg
and here it is in this song library
break-in
[Music]
i think a lot of these unique sounds
generally will make their way into our
music the whole idea is that the world
is small and that sounds are something
that can bring everybody together
we feel like today's world is much more
interconnected and living in new york or
shanghai today that's what we see
in our lives and that reflects in our
music
[Applause]
you